houston on a un problème on envoie des
hommes sur la lune mais recycler le
plastique numéro 6 s'est donc compliqué
ce plastique est l'un des plus répandus
rigide ou en styromousse barquettes pour
aliments petits pots de yogourt paille
ustensiles verres à café une
constellation de produits léger
résistant à la chaleur qui ne coûte pas
cher mais dont le prix pour la planète
est très élevé pourtant le plastique
numéro 6 est entièrement recyclable ce
sont les centres de tri qui ont du mal à
les séparer efficacement des autres
matières seule une minorité accepte de
prendre donc même si vous pensez bien
faire en mettant vos petits pots du
bourg dans le bac bien souvent ils
finissent au dépotoir pas étonnant que
le canada a pour objectif d'éclipsé
totalement six de ces objets à usage
unique en 2027 les centres de tri auront
l'obligation de récupérer le polystyrène
mais en attendant plusieurs
municipalités vous demande d'apporter
vous même le numéro 6 dans un écocentre
c'est un peu comme vous demander la lune
il y a une autre option dans la mesure
du possible vérifiez les emballages à
l'épicerie et éviter le numéro 6 ce sera
un petit geste pour le client mais un
grand pas pour l'environnement passés le
mot
[Musique]